made a nice catch great ball movement by
the pelicans Adams catches with a three
pretty good-looking stroke for the
youngster from UConn who had an
up-and-down career mostly up up there
just about an hour east of Toronto
Williams Kendrick Williams with the
crossover oh yeah great ball fake oh
yeah this kid is a self-made player
playing arguably the most important
position point guard how difficult is
that transition gonna be for John Moran
he's not a one-and-done friend it's
nothing new to see head coaches actually
coach summer league teams we've seen it
before
Audra Dawkins tried to put Grayson Allen
in the hole and couldn't let's watch
this Oh Grayson said no way he's been a
head coach in 2g league so that's not
the issue but just kidding today the
British import working against Grayson
Allen Allen not afraid to get physical
defensively and MacWilliams inside and
Alvin Gentry as you mentioned told us
tried to cut him three different times
and couldn't let him go
alright we're having some technical
issues here with Mark Jones and Fran
Fraschilla
audio there Evans there with a layup for
the Grizzlies the Grizzlies now have six
Harvey dumps it down to Brandon Clark
with the two hands tougher
Clark now with 12-speed Jones worked
really hard and gonna go play for head
coach Jamie Craig head in the San Jose
State Spartans Mountain West Conference
says Bruno Capello Clark
and the flush and finish by kabocha and
the Grizzlies lead back up to six seven
seconds to go needs it for the tie he's
gonna find the open man Tyler Harvey
knocks it down
[Music]
Walker one to go for the game Oh a
couple of minutes of overtime defense
with them and then Alexander Walker he
had a dribble he got a good look mark
and we will have a two-minute overtime
yeah tough shot mark Harvey the floater
man he is smooth that was butter folks
here's Dee Dee there's been a huge in
the second half got by Allen what a
finish
check out the hand cannabis with a
chance for the last shot and the lead
pick-and-roll
Clark the slam in the lead and watch the
double jump in the air but if it goes in
let it go don't put it in right away
they miss Cheatham with the board one
second he didn't get it off in time and
the Grizzlies come back what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content